I think that's interesting to me is that
this this narrative the narrative of
this attack doesn't match sort of
typical international terrorism and the
strategies that attacks usually use so
this terror attack targeted a
marginalized population and it's
interesting to note that most
high-profile terrorist attacks don't hit
marginalized populations for instance
the 911 terrorist hit at the heart of
the American business establishment the
London metro and Madrid train attacks
hit every day commuters and I I think
that that's the strategy of most
terrorism because they want to create
maximum fear in the entire society and
they therefore try to harm people with
whom any member of the society can
easily identify and that's where teens
attack doesn't seem to fit the narrative
he's attacking sort of a subculture
within a subculture and leaving many
Americans open to sort of defensively
tell themselves well you know that
couldn't really have been me I'm not gay
perhaps or I don't go to clubs um what
terrorists usually want to do is scare
everyone by saying that could have been
me and to me that was kind of the first
clue that something something different
than terrorism in the strictest sort of
traditional sense is going on in that in
that case what what is different what do
you see here that could be who could
explain that that difference that you
saw well I think now we're hearing some
very interesting reports that he may
have frequented the pulse nightclub that
he used various gay dating apps it
really seems like something fairly
psychologically convoluted is going on I
mean from a psychological point of view
this episode resembles what what Freud
would have called reaction formation and
that's a defense mechanism in which
individuals have unwanted impulses
within themselves and they attempt to
master or control those impulses by
enacting exactly the opposite behaviors
so if what we're hearing about mateen is
correct it's as if he he needed to
convince himself in the world that he
was the furthest thing from gay by
becoming essentially the most violently
anti gay actor imaginable that's kind of
that would be a traditional Freudian
kind of interpretation and there's some
evidence that behavior follows this
pattern sometimes we know that there's
been much discussion about whether he
was from her he's from a Muslim family
whether that Islamic upbringing if those
things you talked about their work were
going on whether that would play into
some of those pressures he was feeling
what's your what's your view on that I
think definitely I think he may have had
cultural biases against the LGBT
community I would say though that
nothing i've read suggests he was
particularly devout or religious and i
suspect that his for instance
declaration of allegiance to Isis may
not actually mean that much in terms of
his motivations that they may have been
a bit of an afterthought and sort of a
way of legitimizing what he what he was
doing here but I do think that some of
that upbringing could have provided him
with the internal conflicts that it's
not okay to have homoerotic feelings
it's not okay to have those urges which
like I said may have come into conflict
with um with his beliefs